from his debut appearance as a central
character in a disturbing episode of
Atlanta to his wildly mysterious arrival
at the 2018 Emmy Award ceremony there's
a lot we don't know about Teddy Perkins
here's a look behind the scenes to help
fill in the blanks consistently surreal
Teddy Perkins might have been a standout
episode of Atlanta but as weird as it is
it was fully in keeping with the eerie
surrealism established in the world of
the show Glover and his Atlanta team
have never been afraid to tread toward
the surreal in the world of the show
there's a fuzziness on the boundaries of
reality just outside the camera frame
it's Justin Bieber
but the Teddy Perkins episode stands
apart in the Atlanta universe both in
it's unsettling use of heavy white
makeup as a metaphor for the corrosive
effects of Fame and racism and as a
Frankenstein's monster of cinematic
references many pulled from classic
horror references aplenty the episode
starts off like a fairly normal Atlanta
episode the Keith Stanfield's Darius
rents a truck to pick up a free piano
from a wealthy eccentric as soon as
Darius arrives at Teddy Perkins mansion
however the tone of the episode changes
Darius is stepping into a horror movie
and even his wardrobe reflects that
director hero Mariah told Vanity Fair
that he wanted his outfit to evoke James
Caan's look in the 1990 film adaptation
of Stephen King's misery a movie about a
trapped and infirm talent held hostage
sound familiar
when Darius comes across Teddy's
wheelchair-bound brother Bennie in the
basement he's covered in bandages and
wearing sunglasses just like the
Invisible Man from the 1933 horror
classic of the same name and in another
of the episodes classic horror movie
references
there's shades of psycho when a relative
who may or may not exist finally appears
also in a basement there's a sly
reference to another Luke 'if stanfield
role in the modern-day horror classic
get out and get out Stanfield plays
Logan a mind-controlled body swapping
victim who's briefly woken up by a
camera flash in one of the tensest
moments in a film full of them
in the Teddy Perkins episode of Atlanta
Teddy takes Darius's photo suddenly with
a bright flash yeah a big photo person
the most obvious cinematic reference
however is the 1962 psychological
thriller horror film whatever happened
to Baby Jane the film follows two
sisters one obsessed with her childhood
fame as a vaudeville actor and the other
left paraplegic after an accident that
she blames on her sister you wouldn't be
able to do these awful things to me if I
weren't still in this chair the Jackson
connection visually Teddy Perkins is
most obviously inspired by Michael
Jackson but Teddy doesn't just resemble
the King of Pop he tells Darius about
his domineering father with pride in his
voice explicitly comparing him to
Michael's famously abusive father Joe
Jackson Michael Jackson's brother
Jermaine wrote a book largely defending
the abuse they suffered at their
father's hands by combining Jermaine's
defensiveness about his father with a
nod to Michael's alleged skin condition
it further confuses who Teddy Perkins is
and makes the twist that Benny is
actually still alive hit even harder Joe
Jackson isn't the only abusive father to
get a shout out in the episode Teddy
also references Marvin Gaye senior
father of singer Marvin Gaye Gaye was
shot to death by his father and Teddy's
reference to him for shadows the violent
ending of the episode so who is Teddy
Perkins it might have taken at least a
couple viewings before you realized it
but yes that's definitely Atlanta star
and creator Donald Glover playing the
role of Teddy Perkins a bone-chilling
allegory for the perils of black Fame in
America the secret punchline of the
entire episode however is that when the
credits roll it's revealed that Teddy
Perkins was played by himself teddy is
presented as an entity singularly
removed from Glover something that
remained consistent even while the
episode was filming according to Derek
Hayward the actor who plays Benny as
Hayward recalled they were calling him
teddy he acted his teddy
there was no Donald on set whatsoever
Teddy's night out the Teddy Perkins
character actually showed up at the 2018
Emmys even going so far as to pose for
pictures with Donald Glover indicating
that another actor got the Teddy Perkins
treatment for the big night when asked
to it was Atlanta cast members
continually
bird to teddy as a real guy not merely a
role that Glover played keeping the
weirdness alive for at least one more
night much like the episode that bears
his name it seems like the mystery of
the Teddy Perkins character eludes easy
answers
[Music]